[Music]
one of the most exciting trends
happening in web development is the
adoption of web components because they
allow us to build applications that
don't walk us in to a specific framework
or a programming style I'm going to be
using web components in production very
soon so I wanted to share some advanced
concepts that I've learned working with
angular elements and I'll even show you
how to achieve a near perfect white
house performance score with the full
power of angular and firebase in your
Java Script bundle if you're new here
like and subscribe and congrats to
Damian right who's last week's t-shirt
winner but don't worry if you missed out
there's another one of a kind t-shirt
going out this week all you have to do
is leave a comment below over the last
few months I've been building a product
called fire ship IO which is just a
better way for me to deliver my content
to you this project needs to be very
fast in search engine optimized but it
also needs to use firebase for user
authentication and dynamic data the
beauty of web components is that I can
pre render all of my static content and
then bootstrap in custom elements when
they're needed throughout this journey
I've used pretty much every web
component tool that's out there and I
found that angular elements is the most
productive for a larger project but
you'll also want to check out stencil
and lit element which I think are both
very promising
the big advantage of elements is that a
you get the full power of angular and B
your components can share the same
dependency injector tree which means you
can easily share data or functionality
between your custom elements and see the
API is stable and being used in
production at Google today we're going
to build a custom element that can lazy
load an image based on the user scroll
position in the browser when the image
is loading it will show this Facebook
style shimmer placeholder then replace
it with the image when it's fully loaded
now we'll jump into some code but if you
haven't already seen my original angular
elements video you'll want to check that
one out which is a little more basic
level the first thing I want to do is go
into your angular app and then run ng
add at angular elements this will
install the dependencies and also add
the polyfills to ensure that your
elements are compatible with all
browsers then you can go into the app
directory and you'll want to just go
ahead and delete everything except for
the app module you'll also notice I've
generated a couple of regular components
in here as well the first thing I want
to do is register our components as
custom elements I'm assuming angular
will have a better way to do this in the
future but currently we import injector
from angular core and create custom
element from angular elements
now if you want to use your elements
within the context of an angular app you
want to add them to the entry components
array the important thing is that we go
down here to the app module and add the
injector to the constructor if you have
a big project there's probably a whole
bunch of different elements to register
it's the way I like to set this up is to
create an array of tuples so the first
item is the angular class name and then
the second item is the name of the
custom element so that's how you'll
actually use it in the Dom so now we can
loop over these elements and we can
actually de structure them directly in
the for loop which i think is a really
nice-looking piece of JavaScript from
there we can call create custom element
and that gives us a dry way to register
a large number of components now let's
switch gears and see how we can create a
single JavaScript bundle that we can use
outside of angular what you're looking
at here is the build script that I wrote
from my original angular elements video
it just takes all of your production
build files and then concatenates them
into a single file in the public
directory so this works fine but it's
kind of a hack I'd recommend checking
out ngx build plus to extend the default
behavior of the CLI and hopefully the
CLI will just support this
out-of-the-box in the future we'll stick
with the simple approach for now and
I've added a couple of build and serve
scripts to my package JSON it first runs
ng build prod and then it runs the build
script with node so now that we have our
Java Script bundled I'm going to put it
to use and just a static HTML page by
adding it as a script to the head of the
document and you can see down here I'm
using this image lazy custom element
which we'll build here in a few minutes
now I'll go ahead and run a light house
audit and keep in mind I'm also not lazy
loading the images at this point either
we get a first contentful pain in 2.5
seconds and time to interactive is 4
seconds I've also added firebase to my
JavaScript bundle so we have 342
kilobytes here and total that needs to
be loaded before the rest of the page
can render but the great thing about
elements is that we can defer this
script until after the page is rendered
so how do we do that we just go into our
script tag and add defer and we're done
if we run the audit again we get a first
paint in 600 milliseconds which might as
well just be 0 and 3 seconds later we
have the full power of angular and
firebase ready on the page so you can
already get amazing performance with
elements but it's only going to get
better in the next few months here as
angular IV becomes production ready so
that's pretty awesome stuff but I want
to share a few advanced pro tips that
I've learned throughout my experience
working with element
the first thing I'd recommend doing is
disabling angular's automatic change
detection or ng zones which you can do
here in the main TS file the reason for
this is that I've run into some really
hard to debug issues that only happen in
production so you'll find that life is
much easier when you tell the component
explicitly when to re-render now if we
go into the component itself you can see
I have imported everything under the
kitchen sink here from angular core you
won't need all these things in your
elements I just want to show you a few
different techniques at your disposal
and also if you don't want to turn off
zones globally you can do it here at the
component level by doing change
detection strategy on push the next big
decision is whether or not to use the
shadow Dom so the term web components
encompasses a few different features one
of which is obviously custom elements
but another one is the shadow Dom if you
turn the shadow Dom on it means that
your CSS Styles will be encapsulated in
this component that can be a good thing
if you don't want your CSS to bleed out
but it can also make your components
harder to style so it's a trade-off
and the shadow Dom also supports slots
which is something that we'll look at
towards the end of this video now there
are two things that I commonly inject in
the constructor element ref will give us
a reference to the actual Dom api's that
exist on this element the next one is
the change detection ref which allows us
to re-render this component manually
instead of relying on the automatic
change detection because we're
displaying an image we'll have our
custom element behave just like a
regular image tag we'll give it a source
attribute and an alt attribute now the
special thing about our custom element
is that it only displays an image when
it's actually visible in the viewport so
for that we're going to emit our own
custom event called is visible now when
it comes to your internal component
State I recommend keeping the input
values as immutable then you have the
flexibility to manage the state however
you want but here's the pattern that I
find especially effective so we'll
create an object with a couple of
properties on it and we only want to
re-render our component if this state
changes then we'll set up a method here
called set state which takes a key and a
value as its arguments and then we can
go ahead and use the spread syntax to
create a new object and set that as the
new state on the component then we can
guarantee a rerender here by calling
detect changes on the change detection
ref this code might look familiar
because it's inspired by the way react
works contrary to popular belief I do
not hate react overall I found this to
be a very reliable way to work with
elements but there's definitely many
different ways you could do this let's
go ahead and switch over to the HT
and put this to use first we'll set up a
div and if the loaded state is false
then we'll go ahead and show that
placeholder you can check out the full
CSS for that animation in the source
code then we'll set up a figure to wrap
the image itself and we'll only show
this if it's visible based on the user
scroll position on the window then we'll
add an image tag inside of here which
will only be loaded over the network
when this visible property flips to true
just because it's visible doesn't mean
it's loaded yet so we'll also hide the
image until it's fully loaded and then
we'll run an event handler once that
event takes place and the last thing to
make note of is that we're passing our
input source to the actual image source
here so again our custom element feels
just like a regular image tag with some
added benefit so now the challenge is
determining whether or not the user has
scrolled to this element to make that
happen we're going to need to access
some native Dom API s we've already set
up a reference to the native element in
the constructor of this component we can
go ahead and call it here and then we
can call get bounding client rect which
will give us the actual measurements of
that dawn element at the top of the
window is less than or equal to the
window inner height then we know that
that element has been scrolled too and
we also want to check that the element
is not already visible because if it is
and there's no point in running this
code but if it is visible for the first
time then we'll go ahead and run our set
state method which will change the state
and then re render the component another
thing we want to do is emit a custom
event when the element becomes visible
I'll cover the implementation of that in
just a minute so there are two different
situations where we want to calculate
the visibility of the element first when
the component is initialized because if
the element is already in the viewport
then we don't want to wait for the user
to scroll to load it then to listen to
the scroll position we can add host
listener then window : scroll to listen
to the global window scroll event and
when that happens we'll go ahead and
calculate the visibility of the element
so that's how we determine when an
elements visible and also rerender at
when it state changes for the image
itself there's a built-in load event
which will fire when the image is fully
loaded so when that takes place we'll go
ahead and set the loaded state to true
again re rendering the component so the
end result looks like this we start with
a placeholder when the image loads it's
displayed and the placeholder is removed
again the great thing about web
components is that we can interact with
them use
vanilla JavaScript in the Dom so we
could use document query selector to
grab the element and append it somewhere
or change its CSS styles or whatever
by default the internal properties and
methods on the component are not
available when you grab it from the Dom
like this but it can be very useful to
expose a public method that can be used
by the developers working with your
elements for example let's set up a log
method that logs out the internal state
of the component the method that I found
works best although I'd like to see this
improved in future versions of angular
elements is to use the input decorator
the reason we do it this way and not
just attach input to a method is that it
gives us context to this or this
component instance so we can console.log
this state which would otherwise be
undefined if it was a regular method now
another thing that's really useful on
the same note is to emit a custom event
that can be listened to in the browser
so we already have an event you made or
set up on this component and we can emit
through that just like we normally would
an angular and we'll also set up a
custom event in the Dom we'll give that
a name of is visible and then we can
reference our native element and
dispatch the event through it if we go
back to the browser we can now grab this
element from the Dom attach an event
listener to it
and handle it however we want using
vanilla JavaScript or some other
framework so I've set up the is visible
listener and then I'm going to console
like the event when it occurs as soon as
the image becomes visible in the
viewport it logs that custom event to
the console so that takes care of that
the next thing I want to show you is
content projection using slots if you
look at the image on the left here
you'll notice a caption underneath that
has a default header and default caption
if we revisit our static HTML you can
see that I have a couple of spans that
are inside of the Lazy image tags the
spans have a slot attribute which
corresponds to a certain place that
they'll be displayed which will define
inside of our custom element so now I'll
switch over to the component HTML and
we'll go ahead and add a figure caption
then we can include slot tags that have
a specific name that defines where this
content will be displayed this is super
useful when you have components that can
be customized but you don't want the
end-user to have to worry about adding
the required markup to it and if you
want the user to just be able to
transclude some markup inside your
component you can simply drop in a slot
tag that
be considered the default slot and the
user can just pass in whatever HTML they
want and it will be rendered here I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
I have a whole bunch of other ideas for
angular element for future videos so
make sure to LIKE and subscribe and if
you want to take your development to the
next level consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase com go get
access to my following courses my book
as well as a whole bunch of other
resources designed to help you build and
ship apps faster thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you soon